un dernier jour de liberté avant de
rester chez soi
les trois-quarts de l'italie se re
confine dès ce lundi et jusqu'au 6 avril
les écoles et commerces resteront
fermées après avoir rouvert depuis début
février un assouplissement décidé trop
tôt selon certains experts la semaine
dernière la situation s'est soudainement
aggravée avec une augmentation de
presque 15% des contaminations
le week-end dernier l'italie avait
franchi un cap symbolique en devenant le
premier pays d'europe à déplorer plus de
cent mille décès liés aux covit 19 ans
ces mesures sont nécessaires pour éviter
une aggravation de la situation et la
mise en place de mesures encore plus
strictes et ces mesures-là s'accompagne
d'une action du gouvernement pour aider
les familles et les entreprises
l'accélération de la campagne vaccinale
est la seule chose qui nous donne
l'espoir de sortir de cette pandémie
il ya quelques jours j'ai remercié les
italiens pour leur infinie patience
j'ai conscience que les mesures
d'aujourd'hui auront des conséquences
sur l'éducation des enfants sur
l'économie mais aussi l'état
psychologique de nous tous nos stars
toxicology qu'on est dans tout
des italiens qui profitait ce dimanche
des restaurants cafés ou d'une promenade
avant un retour à la vie confinée
on essaye de profiter de cette journée
heureusement il ne pleut pas inscrits
c'est un apéritif nous essayons de
profiter des derniers jours de liberté
évidemment en toute sécurité dans le
respect des règles sanitaires
malheureusement cette situation change
souvent on sait et on ne sait pas donc
je souhaite le meilleur à tout le monde
j'espère que les choses vont s'améliorer
et non pas empirer l'espoir est la seule
chose nous sommes obligés de limiter
notre liberté
je pense que c'est nécessaire pour le
moment et bien sûr nous continuerons sur
cette voie tant que ce sera nécessaire
jusqu'à ce que nous soyons au moins tous
vaccinés
bien sûr c'est très difficile surtout
pour ceux qui n'ont pas de travail
les services de santé eux sont de
nouveau sous tension plus de 22 mille
malades du coup vite 19 sont désormais
hospitalisés et le nombre d'admis en
soins intensifs a grimpé de 25% en un
mois
dans le même temps la vaccination avance
trop lentement sur 60 millions
d'italiens seuls 1,8 million ont reçu
les deux doses du vaccin
quant au ministre de la santé roberto
speranza il n'envisage pas une
amélioration avant la seconde moitié du
printemps